wir schauen nach europa denn dort fallen
überall die maßnahmen nur in deutschland
regeln regeln regeln das treibt viele
bundesbürger auf die straßen wie hier in
magdeburg mehr als 1000 menschen
demonstrierten am abend gegen die krone
maßnahmen und bei diesen unerlaubten
aufzug kam es auch zu rangeleien mit der
polizei pfefferspray wurde eingesetzt
aber es gab auch zahlreiche friedliche
proteste
tja und eben diese corona
demonstrationen die gehen dem
oberbürgermeister christof bolay
gewaltig gegen den strich der spd la der
hat nun klargestellt die stadt
ostfildern bei stuttgart die ist sogar
bereit waffen einzusetzen darüber müssen
wir definitiv sprechen nina schenk bei
uns im studio nena das ist eine harte
ansage ja das ist eine super harte
ansage der mann hat sich der
bürgermeister auch absolut keinen
gefallen getan auf twitter ging es hoch
her man muss hierzu jetzt sagen es gab
jetzt auch eine stellungnahme wo klar
gesagt wird der bürgermeister möchte
keine waffen einsetzen das müssen wir
jetzt hier schon klarstellen aber ich
meine man muss sich auch überlegen was
man für aussagen tätig was man für
kriens tätigt und alleine schon der
gedankengang dass man waffen gebrauchen
könnte gegen demonstranten die gegen die
krone maßnahmen demonstrieren das ist
natürlich völlig daneben was ich ja auch
noch sagen möchte ist ich finde es
generell gerade ein ganz großes problem
in unserer gesellschaft dass
demonstrationen als etwas anstößiges
gesehen werden weil im endeffekt
pervertiert dass unsere demokratie er
nennt das jahr hilfsmittel der
körperlichen gewalt darunter fallen also
schlagstöcke elektroschocker und
pfefferspray wie schätzt du dass ein
dass das zum einsatz kommen soll und
darf genau und da kommen wir jetzt ganz
klar zu dem punkt wo man wirklich sagen
muss ob der bürgermeister eigentlich
noch richtig tickt weil das muss man
sagen der waffengebrauch das nehmen wir
jetzt mal weg das war missverständlich
ausgedrückt aber alleine dass
schlagstöcke und pfefferspray gegen
demonstranten ich habe mir zum beispiel
vor zwei wochen die demonstration in
düsseldorf angeschaut da komm ich her
und habe mich meine stunde an den
straßenrand gestellt einfach mal
zugeschaut ich habe dort in düsseldorf
zu keinem einzigen zeitpunkt mika
natürlich was vorbeigegangen seien auch
nur die möglichkeit gesehen dass mir das
nun schlagstock dann müsste und ich
finde alleine schon er hat ja auch die
demonstrationsverbote
und alleine das demonstrationen verboten
werden und dann noch mit so etwas
gedroht wird da müssen wir uns wirklich
fragen was ist in diesem land los und
ich frage mich schon lange wo bleibt der
aufschrei wir müssen ganz schnell war
eine sache dürfen wir uns nicht
einlassen
es mischen sich leider auch unter
mancher dieser kroner spaziergänger
mischen sich auch krude menschen das ist
auch gewalt statt und da müssen wir auch
stark als der modell demokratien
gegenhalten kein finger breit dem hass
aber wir brauchen natürlich orte wo
menschen friedlich demonstrieren gehen
können und wenn bürgermeister wie dieser
spd-mann demonstration eigen schon
grundlegend anstößig finden grundlegend
falschen grundlegend verbieten wollen
und dann noch mit solchen mitteln
dagegen vorgehen wollen dann sind wir
ehrlich gesagt am ende in diesem land
wir wollen wir schauen wie es anders
geht in der anderen ländern geht man da
doch ganz anders mit um in
großbritannien da sind ja schon die
massen gefallen und auch in dänemark
lebt jetzt wieder in freiheit schauen
wir mal wie die dänen den übergang
zurück zur normalität so verkraftet
haben
europa verabschiedet sich nach und nach
von den chor ohne regeln wir in
deutschland träumen noch davon ein
freedom day für das ganze land keine
masken keine impfpass kontrollen
geöffnete clubs und keine corona regeln
die briten haben den anfang gemacht die
der innen ziehen jetzt am ersten februar
nach aber während in london bereits am
wochenende ungeniert in clubs bars und
auf der straße gefeiert wurde machen die
dänen noch am abend vor dem freedom day
kräftig um 22 uhr wird die letzte runde
alkohol ausgeschenkt um 23 uhr sind alle
restaurants und bars
auch am letzten coroner regel abend
halten sich hier alle an die regeln
obwohl den freedom day so viele herbei
gesehnt haben also das worauf ich mich
am meisten freue ist tatsächlich dass es
einfach nicht mehr diese beschränkung
gibt weil ich hier war ja einfach die
regel dass so ab 10 uhr kannst du keinen
alkohol mehr ausschenken und ab 11 uhr
ist dann halt alles dicht aber ich freue
mich tatsächlich darauf dass man nach
dem dinner nach dem essen gehen einfach
noch weiterziehen kann eine bar und da
eben ja nicht irgendwann dieser coole
art unterbrochen wird und man dann nach
hause gehen muss und da freue ich mich
am meisten drauf ein tag an dem alle
coroner regeln wegfallen macht das
überhaupt sinn in kopenhagen meinen die
menschen ja es wird zeit das leben ohne
chor ohne regeln und einschränkungen
anzufangen trotz hoher inzidenz zahlen
wir gehen los und feiern dass wir
sind einfach so glücklich nicht mehr in
ein leben gedrückt zu werden dass wir
nicht leben wollen
obwohl es bereits der zweite freedom day
in fünf monaten ist sind die dänen
optimistisch dass diesmal alles gut wird
sie haben vertrauen in ihre regierung
die hat die korona beschränkungen in den
vergangenen wochen für beendet erklärt
und ist damit der empfehlung der
virologen gefolgt die begründung mehr
als 81 prozent der dänen sind
vollständig geimpft und die omikron
variante sei relativ harmlos
ein tag an dem alle coroner regeln
abgeschafft werden ein tag der freiheit
kann das auch in deutschland gelingen
die bedingungen sind jedenfalls ähnlich
und das bedürfnis der menschen nach
normalität und nach einem corona regel
freien alltag mindestens genauso groß
und bleibt zugeschaltet aus kopenhagen
ist jetzt bild reporterin klara marie
becker clara erzählt uns mal wie hat
sich das angefühlt das leben wieder in
freiheit
ja gestern abend als wir unterwegs waren
hier in kopenhagen im bau- und
studentenviertel
galten die korona regeln ja leider noch
deswegen haben wir noch nicht die
freiheit hier in kopenhagen mitbekommen
heute war es tatsächlich schon so man
hat die leute ohne masken gesehen in
geschäften in cafés in restaurants das
heißt ja ab heute gelten diese regeln
nicht mehr keine abstandsregeln kein
öfters nachweis
man muss man darf wieder in clubs gehen
ist werden wieder größere
veranstaltungen stattfinden und wir
haben's ja auch schon im beitrag gerade
gehört die dänen freuen sich wirklich
riesig darauf das ist ja schon der
zweite freedom day in fünf monaten hier
in dänemark aber wir haben auch gehört
als wir gestern mit den leuten
gesprochen haben die menschen dann
wirklich vertrauen dass es jetzt erstmal
dabei bleibt der vertrauen in ihre
regierung die eben die pandemie jetzt
für nicht mehr gesellschaftskritisch
oder cobit 19 nicht mehr als eine
gesellschaftskritische krankheit
eingestuft hat und die ideen freuen sich
jetzt riesig darauf hier am kommenden
wochenende party zu machen gestern abend
war noch nicht so viel los in den bars
muss es eben montagabend und genau um 11
uhr mussten auch alle noch zu machen ab
heute abend wird sich das dann wohl
ändern vielen dank nach dänemark an
unsere reporterin klarer marie bayern
und auch vielen dank an nina schenk im
studio